et que j'ouvre notre second débat
pendant toute cette semaine il sera
consacré à l'Ukraine un an après
l'invasion russe nous ferons le bilan de
ses 12 mois de guerre on verra aussi
comment ce conflit a rebattu les cartes
militaires au sein de l'Union européenne
et puis on va évidemment analyser les
les conséquences économiques profondes
de cette guerre mondialisée mais pour
commencer aujourd'hui c'est un portrait
que je vous propose avec Audrey veetta
celui d'un ancien humoriste devenu chef
de guerre volody mirzelanski
l'image est historique le président
américain Joe Biden est accueilli à Kiev
par volody mirzuelinski pour la toute
première fois depuis l'invasion russe le
symbole du soutien de l'Occident aux
côtés de l'homme qui incarne à lui seul
la résistance face à Vladimir Poutine
pourtant il y a encore un an la
popularité de Zelenski est lu en 2019 à
la surprise générale était en berne pas
juger trop faible face à la corruption
et à Poutine incapable de se débarrasser
de son ancienne image de clown acteurs
pour le petit écran un costume de
président trop grand jusqu'au 24 février
les bons bruses s'abattent sur l'Ukraine
et sa capitale volo des myrski devient
l'homme à abattre les États-Unis lui
propose de l'ex-filtré il refuse au
contraire il se saisit de son téléphone
il sort dans les rues de Kiev et fait ce
qu'il sait faire le mieux il communique
bonjour à tous il y a beaucoup de
fausses informations sur internet en ce
moment ils ont que je demande à notre
armée de déposer les armes et qu'une
évacuation est en cours et bien je suis
là on ne va pas déposer les armes et on
va défendre notre pays gloire à
l'Ukraine il endos le rôle de sa vie
celui de chef de guerre pour s'opposer à
la propagande de Poutine pull kaki sur
le dos treillis par balle va visiter les
villes touchées par l'offensive toujours
sous l'oeil des caméras pour galvaniser
son peuple à l'allure martiale il faut
ajouter les discours offensifs quand ils
rencontrent ses alliés pour leur
demander plus d'aide militaire comme ce
jour de février 2023 au Parlement
européen lors de son deuxième le
déplacement en dehors de l'Ukraine
depuis la guerre nous nous défendons
contre la force la plus anti-européenne
du monde moderne nous défendons nous les
Ukrainiens sur le champ de bataille nous
vous défendons
qui l'ancienne acteur cherche aussi des
rôles médiatiques dans le monde du
cinéma comme avec cet apparition
surprise à l'ouverture du Festival de
Cannes des gens meurent tous les jours
ne vont pas se relever après le club de
fin cinéma va-t-il se taire ou va-t-il
en parler nous avons besoin d'un nouveau
chapeling qui prouvera une fois de plus
que le cinéma n'est pas muet
il sait qu'il doit tout faire pour
rester au centre de l'attention
internationale seule option pour ne pas
perdre sa guerre face à la Russie
voilà 45 minutes pour un portrait de
volo dix meilleurs zelens qui voilà ce
que je vous propose en ouverture de
cette semaine spéciale consacrée à la
guerre en Ukraine rien de chemin bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes grand reporter au
journal Le Monde et vous signez une une
série d'articles intitulés les 5 vies de
volodime ski Alexandra goujon bonsoir
bienvenue maître de conférence à
l'Université de Bourgogne enseignante à
Sciences Po spécialiste de l'Ukraine et
autrice de ce livre l'Ukraine de
l'indépendance à la guerre publié aux
éditions Le Cavalier Bleu galaïa week
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes grands
reporter ancien directeur de la
rédaction anglophone de France 24 et je
cite votre livre zelens qui l'Ukraine
dans le sang lui aux éditions du Rocher
signal que les droits sont renversés au
mouvement intercu culturel France
Ukraine et Frédéric says et éditoris
politique est resté à mes côtés
rebonsoir Frédéric c'est un exercice
compliqué que je vais vous demander pour
pour commencer parce que c'est toujours
difficile de réduire un homme à une
anecdote un trait de caractère ou un
adjectif mais rien de chemin vous je
vous refile la patate chaude je suis
désolé mais vous vous qui voilà vous
allez travailler sur vous dites les cinq
les cinq vidéos qu'est-ce qui ressort
finalement vous êtes arrivés avec ce que
vous saviez du personnage et puis
l'enquête vous peut-être amenez beaucoup
de publicités c'était le héros puisque
c'est comme ça qu'on a découvert depuis
un an et je il y avait deux choses que
j'ignorais complètement je ne
connaissais pas sa vie russe si je puis
dire ces années russes j'ignorais qu'il
avait pu louer pendant 3 ans un
appartement à Moscou parce que je pense
que depuis la gare c'est quelque chose
qui est très occulté et puis l'autre
chose qui m'a fasciné aussi c'est de
découvrir qu'elle est pas fait son
service militaire donc ça je trouve que
pour quelqu'un comme ça qu'ils n'ont pas
un chef de guerre mais un chef d'État en
guerre c'est quand même intéressant à
prendre effectivement c'est surprenant
galeries qu'est-ce que vous décrivez
alors j'ai j'ai trouvé ça dans les
articles ce mec à la tête de jouets pour
enfants est en réalité une lame de
rasoir et Poutine ce ce blesse en
essayant de la manipuler ça ça vous a
frappé oui oui c'est à dire que on en
parlait justement avant concentrer sur
ce plateau cette première confrontation
entre zélenski et Poutine ici même à
Paris sous les ors du Palais de l'Élysée
en étant 2019 et le président de de le
président français avec la chancelière
allemande Angela Merkel c'est le format
Normandie les reçoit tous les deux
puissent qui se retrouve face à Vladimir
Poutine et on voit Zellen ski qui
connaît bien les lumières mais qui
extrêmement nerveux faut savoir qu'il y
a des manifestations devant son palais
présidentiel à qui parce que beaucoup de
d'ukrainien ukrainienne craignent qu'il
ne fasse trop de de concessions que ce
soit entre guillemets un vendu à à la
Russie ou qu'il ne soit trop faible tout
simplement et puis Vladimir Poutine avec
un petit air quoi lui dit retourne-toi
les photographes sont juste là parce que
vous savez il y a la traditionnelle
photographique quand on fait rentrer les
photographes et on sent cette première
interaction beaucoup de violence dans
dans le regard et l'intention de
Vladimir Poutine mais vous demandiez une
une formule une manière de le résumer je
pense que la lumière routine éprouve
cela tout de suite c'est-à-dire qu'il se
rend compte que ce type finalement est
très costaud et qu'il a affaire à un
clown qui a plus d'un tour dans dans son
sac en fait pour moi Zelenski c'est
c'est l'improbable face à l'impensable
parce que personne ne l'attends zellens
qui est certainement pas dans les habits
qu'il revêt aujourd'hui aux yeux du du
monde entier et l'impensable c'est la
tragédie à laquelle le pays dont il a la
responsabilité et actuellement
confrontés
bien la société
ukrainienne il y a Zelenski qui porte
son peuple mais il y a aussi son peuple
qui le porte enfin il faut aussi
retourner l'analyse c'est important tu
crois souvent des faits miroir en fait
on a tendance à penser que alors
effectivement que volodièreski incarne
la résistance Ukraine mais en fait
ce que font les Ukrainiens sur le
terrain oblige vos le dix meilleurs
Hélène ce qui aussi et on parle beaucoup
aussi de ces communications à
l'international là on l'a vu
à sa population tous les soirs tous les
soirs pour faire le point là où ils en
sont là où ils ont réussi à obtenir des
arbres ou pas et remercier les soldats
et les citoyens les élèves ski c'est
qu'il est surveillé par sa population
c'est à dire que en Ukraine un chef
d'État n'a jamais un blanc enceinte
total et et donc il y a une vigilance il
y a une surveillance et donc il est
attendu au tournant donc il y a
effectivement cette un rapport de
confiance pour le moment dans ce combat
face face à la Russie mais qui est qui
est tenue
l'événement du jour en Ukraine
évidemment on va y revenir rapidement
parce que là on est dans une partie on
va prendre le temps de vraiment de
raconter l'histoire des Hélène ski mais
c'est évidemment la visite du président
américain
est-ce que vous voulez des meilleures
années ce qui parle d'égal à égal avec
un Joe Biden ou malgré tout il est dans
un état un tel état de dépendance
militaire que c'est que c'est impossible
comment vous l'analysez en fait dans sa
maturation politique il a compris la
chose suivante c'est que son pays est
dans un état d'indigence militaire
financière qui le met effectivement en
position de faiblesse mais il a une
telle force de par sa position morale
qu'il peut jouer d'égal à égal avec Joe
Biden parce que Joe Biden le dit
lui-même le président des États-Unis
c'est un combat entre la démocratie et
l'autocratie qui se joue sur son terrain
et zellenski sait qu'il incarne cela et
donc dans sa maturation géopolitique il
a appris qu'il était énormément
dépendant à l'égard de ces alliés le
premier d'entre eux les États-Unis mais
qu'il peut aussi rentrer dans un rapport
de force avec eux parce qu'aujourd'hui
zellens qui est l'un des hommes les plus
puissants et les plus influents au monde
si vous voulez être quelqu'un dans
l'univers géopolitique aujourd'hui
occidental en tous les cas vous devez
être vu physiquement aux côtés de
zellens qui si vous vous frottez à lui
ou que vous lui déplaisez vous risquez
de le payer je rappellerai juste un
épisode quand l'Allemagne à tergiverser
peu de temps après février le président
allemand a annoncé qu'il allait se
rendre à kif Franck Walter par ailleurs
et Zelenski lui a fait dire rentre chez
toi je ne veux pas toi à qui donc il a
très rapidement c'était avant l'annonce
de livraison des Charlots
que maintenant elle va livrer des chars
léopard il y a une révolution
copernicienne il se passait beaucoup de
choses entre-temps mais tout ça pour
dire queenski oui il était la fois très
faible par cette situation de dépendance
mais de par sa la force morale de son
combat il est également très très fort
alors on parlait de Zelenski face à Joe
Biden on va évoquer maintenant et
quentacle mais les relations entre entre
le président ukrainien et le président
français ils se sont parlés au téléphone
ce week-end c'est ça exactement ils se
sont parlés hier soir Thomas l'occasion
pour Emmanuel Macron de clarifier sa
position directement auprès du président
ukrainien et aller se communiquer qui a
futé dans la presse le président
République qui a réaffirmé son
attachement au plan de paix en 10 points
proposés par le président zellinski et
il lui a assuré qu'il soutiendrait cette
initiative sur la scène internationale
lors des prochains événements
diplomatiques même message du côté
ukrainien on l'a vu sur Twitter cette
fois-ci et voilà pour suite d'un
dialogue amical avec le président
Emmanuel Macron j'ai abordé nous avons
abordé la coopération en matière de
défense et de et le rapprochement de la
paix nous avons résumé les résultats des
visites récentes et discuter des
éléments diplomatiques à venir en
particulier la mise en œuvre du plan en
10 étapes ce plan de paix en dix étapes
un volodime zenenski elle avait
explicité lors du G20 de Bali en
Indonésie en novembre dernier il fixe
les revendications ukrainiennes
approvisionnement énergétique retour des
personnes déportées et des prisonniers
ou encore rétablissement de l'intégrité
territoriale de l'Ukraine Thomas
Emmanuel Macron qui avait explicité la
position de la France auprès de
plusieurs journalistes oui c'était
effectivement au retour du sommet annuel
de l'OTAN de Munich donc ça c'était la
veille on oublie les propos prononcés en
juin dernier sur le fait de ne pas
vouloir humilier la Russie cette fois-ci
Emmanuel Macron est claire auprès de ses
journalistes il a dit effectivement ce
week-end également je veux la défaite de
la Russie je veux que l'Ukraine puisse
défendre sa position une nuance
cependant immédiatement cette
déclaration avec ses propos mais je suis
convaincu qu'à la fin ça ne se réglera
pas militairement je ne pense pas comme
certains qu'il faut défaire la réussite
totalement l'écraser sur son sol Thomas
ses observateurs veulent avant tout
écraser la Russie cela n'a jamais été la
position de la France et cela ne sera
jamais évident cette partie de la
déclaration Emmanuel Macron a marqué
dans cette interview qui était réalisée
dans l'avion ce vendredi soir il a parlé
de négocier y compris avec la meilleure
poutine voilà et c'est là que les
divergences apparaissent effectivement
avec le président ukrainien Emmanuel
Macron qui a expliqué pensons-nous
sincèrement qu'une solution démocratique
émergera de la société civile russe
présente sur place après ces années de
durcissement et en plein conflit je le
souhaite vivement mais je n'y crois pas
vraiment a-t-il dit et toutes les
options autre que Vladimir Poutine au
sein du système actuel me paraissent
pire or et bien cette déclaration elle a
été rapportée à voldemer Zelenski par un
journal italien le courrier de la Serra
qui a répondu directement à Emmanuel
Macron et il a répondu que il jugeait ce
dialogue cette discussion
inutile avec le président russe Emmanuel
Macron perd son temps a dit le président
ukrainien on voit donc que c'est
compliqué même lorsque ça semble aller
mieux il dit enfin je suis arrivé à la
conclusion que nous ne sommes pas en
mesure de changer l'attitude de la
Russie si les Russes ont décidé de
s'isoler dans leur rêve de rebâtir
l'empire soviétique nous ne pouvons rien
y faire il leur appartient de choisir ou
non de coopérer à déclarer le chef de
l'État ukrainien merci beaucoup Quentin
calmé pour pour toutes ces explications
ils ont le même âge je crois Emmanuel
Macron et volody merzelinski Ariane
chemin la là on le voit c'est c'est un
lien de confiance qui a toujours été
compliqué
très compliqué ça ça s'arrange mais pas
vraiment quoi si si je suis un peu
trivial aujourd'hui Emmanuel Macron il
l'a redit ce flat c'est d'avoir reçu
volody mirzuelins de la présidentielle
il était le seul pays
va recevoir à la fois sur rival prochain
coup et j'ai inscrit mais c'est très
compliqué ce qui me fascine dans cette
histoire c'est pourquoi Emmanuel Macron
fait-il des offres comme ça sur la
diplomatie c'est quand même quelque
chose de très très nouveau parce qu'au
fond du coup on voit le front de sa
pensée et chaque fois qu'il fait un
petit bouger comme on dit ou qu'il
change de braquer en fait on n'y croit
plus désormais puisque 15 jours après il
change d'avis on voit bien que ça
matrice fondamentale c'est quand même
une matrice qui n'est pas celle
évidemment ni de la Pologne ni de
l'Angleterre ni des États-Unis il y a un
fond chez lui qui est une matrice qui
vient je pense sa formation un peu
souverainiste ou pas que le seul parti
auquel il a adhéré c'est le parti de
Jean-Pierre Chevènement je pense que ça
lui il a une vision très très classique
de la dico Massie il continue même s'il
dit le contraire essayer de penser que
il peut être une force et s'interposer
entre un tête-à-tête entre Washington et
Moscou ça ne marche pas mais il continue
allez on va prendre le temps de de
présenter à l'enfance de vous le dit
meilleur et si vous l’avez évoqué tout à
l'heure Ariane chemin c'est je voudrais
vous entendre là-dessus gala Fenwick
c'est une enfance soviétique ah oui
parce que c'était encore l'URSS
évidemment et c'est un peu un tabou
aujourd'hui c'est intéressant ça
c'est pas c'est pas un tabou c'est à
dire que l'Ukraine est en train de
passer par une phase de dérussification
massive mais qui correspond si vous
voyez que qui n'est ni plus ni moins
qu'un retour naturel par rapport à ce
que la Russie est en train d'essayer de
faire en Ukraine c'est-à-dire une
russification par le fer et dans le sang
donc non non tout le monde sait que que
zellens qui est né russophone dans une
petite ville du sud-est où on parlait
voilà russe à la maison qu'il était même
russophile mais ce qui ne veut pas dire
anti-ukrainien et certainement pas trop
Poutine donc non son enfance si vous
voulez dans cet univers là qui est
effectivement un univers soviétique
n'est pas un tabou en revanche parler de
ces années là et c'est très clairement
dit dans dans les années dans les des
articles d'Ariane chemin qui qui
paraissent ces jours-ci et je pense
notamment au Léna cravet ce qui est une
amie très très proche elle dit écoutez
vous savez c'est pas de ça dont j'ai
envie de parler en ce moment je préfère
ne pas en parler c'est pour ça je dis
tabou c'est aussi ce qui m'a frappé moi
dans votre intégré d'ailleurs parce que
j'ai en plus j'ai adoré son livre que je
trouve génial mais effectivement dans
soi c'est pas un tabou mais depuis la
guerre ça l'est moi je m'en souviens
parce que j'avais rencontré Elena
gélinseca et je lui avais demandé mais
vous avez été chez les pionniers qui est
l'organisation de jeunesse du Parti
communiste elle avait il lui dit la
question ensuite je lui avais dit vous
connaissez Moscou elle n'avait pas
répondu la vérité c'est qu'elle connaît
très très bien Moscou et qu'elle a été
chez des pionniers c'est quelque chose
qu'on ne peut pas dire et effectivement
qu'à la gare a raison cette actrice qui
s'appelle Léna cravate je lui demandais
de raconter leurs années moscovites
parce que toute cette bande qui faisait
du stand up a été à Moscou et là j'ai vu
son visage changer elle m'a dit on
descendait à l'hôtel de l'amitié je
n'arrive pas à vous en parler ça me fait
trop de mal
l'hôtel dans lequel il descendait à
Moscou s'appelait l'hôtel d'amitié
effectivement
Alexandra goujon sur on peut élargir
cette réflexion sur la l'histoire russe
de volody mers evanski à toute une
partie du peuple ukrainien aujourd'hui
alors est-ce que comment c'est vécu
cette partie de leur histoire est-ce que
c'est un non dit est-ce que comment
c'est perçu c'est une histoire russe
c'est une histoire soviétique avant tout
une histoire soviétique puis russe au
moment de l'indépendance et j'allais
dire une histoire ruisseau Ukraine on
navigue entre l'Ukraine et la Russie
ce qu'on fait beaucoup de gens de
notamment de l'est de l'Ukraine qui
allait travailler la migration
pendulaire ça se fait et pas simplement
pour faire du du stand-up mais aussi
pour aller travailler dans le bâtiment
dans les villes comme Rostov ou ou
Moscou je crois que justement Zelenski
et c'est ce qu'il a fait lire d'ailleurs
c'est quelqu'un qui incarne cette
population russophone
patriote ukrainienne et ça c'est quelque
chose qu'on n'a pas voulu voir on a
voulu assimiler les russophone
premièrement au prorus un adjectif en
fait dont on sait pas trop ce qu'il veut
dire parce que prorus ça peut vouloir
dire moi j'ai une entreprise dans l'est
et j'ai envie de vendre va marchandise à
Moscou et je j'aimerais que les droites
douane soient les moins chers possibles
les moins élevés donc ça c'est logique
ce qui ne veut pas dire je veux que
l'armée ukrainienne Vienne occuper mon
territoire et qu'on mette un maire russe
à la place du mer ukrainien qui gouverne
Herson donc en fait on voilà on n'a pas
voulu voir une construction nationale
qui existe en Ukraine depuis 91 et
surtout une génération à leursinsky est
un peu plus âgé mais de trentenaires qui
n'a pas connu l'Union soviétique et ça
c'est une erreur de Poutine aussi parce
que vous dites on n'a pas voulu voir
c'est à dire en Europe de l'Ouest un peu
moins aux États-Unis au Royaume-Uni
effectivement en Europe de l'Ouest on a
complètement on va complètement on a eu
tendance effectivement à adopter le
discours qui nous venait de Russie comme
on a pu le faire du temps de l'Empire
russe du temps de l'Union Soviétique où
on voyait les choses depuis Moscou
lorsqu'on voit les choses depuis Moscou
on ne sait pas vraiment ce qui se passe
à Kiev alors on peut pas raconter
l'histoire des elenski sans rappeler
évidemment ce qui a déjà été beaucoup
dit mais c'est quand même étonnant cette
série télévisée serviteur du peuple
série de prémonitoire on va en voir
quelques images dans laquelle il incarne
un professeur d'histoire qui accède à la
présidence de l'Ukraine succès populaire
énorme je pense qu'on a les images mais
elle devrait arriver succès populaire
énorme en 2015 qui ouvre la voie à sa
carrière politique c'est pas grave on va
écouter ce qu'on dit Nicolas soderlunk
est détenteur des droits télé de la
série qui évidemment depuis que la
guerre a commencé serrer elle s'est
vendue dans le monde entier en écoute
Nicolas Soderlund
you wood and believe that I on aurait
jamais pu imaginer que celui qui était
un comédien très drôle très populaire
émet du public elle est devenue
solidaire mondial qui incarne et qui
parle pour toute une nation cette
transformation est incroyable je dois
dire je pense que peu de gens auraient
pu faire la même chose que lui et il
reste à qui
il sait que des gens essaient de le tuer
mais il reste quand même je pense que
c'est fantastique
nichées dans un coin de la régie les
images de souhaitons mais enfin vous les
connaissez vous les avez vu largement
peut-être qu'il faut à rien de chemin
rappeler comment et parce que vous
l'avez dit c'est du stand-up mais comme
comment il vient à la comédie vient la
comédie avec une espèce de démission de
vieilles émissions soviétique remise au
goût du jour c'est quoi l'histoire du
milieu des années 60 qui a été
interrompu plusieurs fois pour les
raisons politiques qui revient avec la
pérestroika qui s'appelle les KVN ça
veut dire club de rigolo à l'aise voilà
et c'est une sorte il y a pas
l'équivalent d'émissions de télé crochet
je dirais comme une sorte de jeu sans
frontières où on s'affronte avec des
concours de de répartie de stand up etc
et c'est le moyen que trouve enfin même
si c'est pas pensé
volody mercedescouilles et tous ses amis
pour s'échapper au fond de leur vie de
leur ville de Rivery ils vont passer les
étapes ils vont remporter des des
espèces de duels avec d'autres ducs
d'autres villes à Sotchi puis ça y est
ils arrivent sur la scène russe c'est
pour ça qu'il dit beaucoup de temps et
qu'ils se mettent à jouer un peu partout
faire des tournées et jouer aussi devant
des dignitaires soviétiques enfin russe
pardon puisqu'on est après 91 parce que
c'est un jeu populaire et qu'on aime ça
donc on convoque dans des soirées
privées ils se retrouvent à jouer devant
Metz une fois que il est dans une grande
salle à Moscou et Poutine et au fond
même si il dit aujourd'hui que ils ne
sont pas vraiment vus et que Poutine à
Paris donc c'est vraiment un phénomène
c'est aussi à la fois une école de
formation une école qui vous aide à
parler et puis sans doute qu'il faudrait
revenir sur l'importance de de ce jeu un
jour c'est aussi un moyen de fédérer
toutes les axes républiques soviétiques
qui toutes participent à ce jeu c'est
peut-être du j'ai pas du soft power je
ne sais pas alors on va parler de la
force du verbe parce que c'est aussi
pour ça que je voulais qu'on ouvre ce
chapitre sur Zelenski comédien humoriste
habitué des tréteaux et des plateaux
télé la force du verbe fallait essayer
c'est quand même très important avec un
aspect qui vous a particulièrement
marqué dans les discours du président
ukrainien à l'étranger ou adressé à des
pays étrangers d'ailleurs c'est vrai
qu'il y en a beaucoup un des discours à
l'étranger évidemment volody mercedeski
cherche à ne pas être isolé sur la scène
internationale et donc il s'exprime
régulièrement devant les parlements
étrangers parfois en personne en
physique on l'a vu récemment dans sa
mini tournée européenne et puis parfois
évidemment en visioconférence pour des
raisons de sécurité alors on pourrait
penser que toutes ces allocutions se
ressemblent entre elles après tout c'est
la guerre il y a des tranchées qu'est-ce
qui pourrait dire de différents à chacun
de ces interlocuteurs et pourtant ces
discours ne sont jamais exactement les
mêmes ils ont tous l'objectif commun de
demander des armes du financement de
l'aide mais le président ukrainien prend
toujours soin de placer quelques
éléments qui vont parler au cœur de ces
interlocuteurs qui vont montrer qu'il
connaît leur histoire et leurs
sentiments par exemple en décembre
dernier quand il s'exprime à Washington
devant les parlementaires zellenski se
place sous la tutelle d'un grand
président américain qui a lui aussi
connu la guerre
devant vous aujourd'hui je me souviens
des mots du président Franklin de la no
Roosevelt
qui je pense correspondent à ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui le peuple américain
dans sa juste puissance l'emportera
jusqu'à la victoire absolue les
Ukrainiens aussi l'emporteront de
manière absolue
alors cité Roosevelt évidemment c'est ce
placer sous les auspices d'un président
qui est populaire qui est aussi
victorieux c'est cette image victorieuse
aux États-Unis c'est aussi adresser le
message attention à l'isolationnisme
puisque vous savez que Franklin adelano
Roosevelt a dû lutter contre un congrès
qui ne voulait surtout pas partir en
guerre au moment de la deuxième guerre
mondiale qui voulait rester dans sa
neutralité bien tranquille pendant que
en Europe la guerre faisait rage il y a
donc aussi ce message subliminal ne
restez pas chez vous au prétexte que ce
serait trop loin trop cher trop inconnu
allez-y aidez-nous c'est maintenant
c'est au nom de la démocratie alors donc
ça c'est l'exemple américain autre
exemple en Israël exactement c'était en
mars 2022 là pour le coup une
visioconférence ouais de vous le dire
Zelenski devant le parlement israélien
la knees 7 et là encore pour convaincre
ses interlocuteurs il mobilise
l'histoire
gratis
le 24 février 1920 le Parti national
socialiste des travailleurs d'Allemagne
et fondés le parti qui a pris des
millions de vies détruit des pays
entiers à essayer de détruire des
nations
plus tard le 24 février un ordre
criminel a été émis pour lancer une
invasion russe à grande échelle de
l'Ukraine provenant mangeable
24 février à l'autre évidemment c'est la
vise à développer l'empathie à dire nous
avons des épreuves communes un destin
commun alors il va des fois un peu loin
d'ailleurs ça n'a pas été très bien
accueilli en Israël ce discours là il y
a une partie de l'opinion qui a estimé
que le parallèle était un peu douteux un
peu excessif qu'il n'aurait pas dû le
faire autre exemple alors là on est face
enfin il est face au parlementaire
britannique il a il adopte un humour sob
oui il a encore une petite allusion un
élément de l'identité nationale du pays
auquel il s'adresse et quoi de plus
typiquement britannique que le thé
quand j'ai quitté le Parlement
britannique il y a 2 ans je vous ai
remercié pour un délicieux thé anglais
de
je quitterai le Parlement aujourd'hui en
vous remerciant tous en avance pour de
puissants avions anglais
voilà on entend bien les clins d'oeils
qui sont envoyés évidemment le thé mais
aussi les avions dans le discours il
fait allusion évidemment la résistance
de l'Armée de l'Air britannique en 1940
contre les avions allemands il se place
là aussi dans cette continuité les ailes
de la liberté évidemment l'expression
n'est pas prononcée au hasard alors ce
sont des discours qui généralement sont
assez réussi en cela justement qu'ils
arrivent à toucher au cœur aussi des
opinions publiques c'est à elle qu'il
s'adresse au travers de ces allocutions
d'ailleurs on aimerait bien savoir
comment sont conçus par une équipe
autour de divers elenski c'est discours
particulièrement travaillés avec ces
éléments de mimétisme d'empathie
d'identification volodières zenenski ne
joue pas seulement sur l'altruisme de ce
qu'il écoute sur le mode venez m'aider
car évidemment ici c'est la guerre mais
aussi sur leur égoïsme venez car
finalement nous nous ressemblons
beaucoup merci Frédéric Fenwick dans les
heures qui suivent l'invasion russe il y
a un premier message de Paulo
diverselenski sur les réseaux sociaux
repris évidemment par les médias du
monde entier depuis je crois qu'il le
fait quasiment
quotidiennement est-ce que vous diriez
qu'il donne le la c'est à dire qu'il a
choisi le registre
verbal peut-être même aussi des valeurs
le registre de cette guerre oui oui tout
à l'heure vous avez une expression vous
avez parlé de la force du verbe c'est
plus encore que cela c'est la victoire
du verbe et c'est pour cela que c'est
Chaplin qui devient Churchill parce que
dans cette nuit fatidique du 23 au 24
février c'est l'une des dernières fois
qu'on le voit dans ce costume noir
sombre cintré il est sous une lumière
taninite tamisée avec une carte de
l'Ukraine derrière lui il commence par
s'adresser à ses concitoyens Ukrainiens
donc il leur dit nous allons vivre des
heures très très sombres puis il marque
une petite pause et alors il commence à
parler en russe et il dit aux Russes
il leur dit vous êtes aux portes de
notre pays quand vous franchirez cette
frontière qui sépare votre pays d'une
autre vous verrez nos yeux et non nos
dos et donc c'était ce que disait la
personne tout à l'heure le producteur
nous vous avez passé l'extrait qui a
produit serviteur du peuple zellens qui
c'est l'homme qui reste et avec le verbe
il va faire deux choses il va d'abord
définir son rôle qui n'est pas celui de
d'une personne qui n'a absolument aucune
expérience militaire et qui va
s'improviser chef du guerre au sens de
réunir ses généraux déplacer des
garnisons sur des cartes etc non ça va
être le communicant chef et deuxième
chose par sa maîtrise du verbe et son
verbe au il va à la fois
galvaniser son peuple et ukrainien et
donc l'unir le rassembler mais plus
encore que cela il va faire que bien
au-delà des frontières de son pays vous
ici moi ici nous tous ici nous
ressentions dans notre la douleur des
Ukrainiens et des ukrainiennes et
rappelez-vous juste une scène parce que
vous passez excellent vraiment ce que
vous racontiez parce que c'est ça
Roosevelt le raté à l'acné 7 la grande
réussite dans Westminster Hall quelques
plus de 40 ans après deux Gaules qui
avaient prononcé un grand discours sur
ces mêmes marches devant des
parlementaires britanniques debout
Zelenski si vous voulez son arme de
guerre c'est la communication et vos
trois exemples sont intéressants parce
que la communication quand c'est une
arme de guerre c'est comme une arme si
vous vous en servez mal vous pouvez vous
blesser vous pouvez blesser vos alliés
en revanche si vous en servez
correctement vous faites très très mal à
vos ennemis et c'est en cela qu'il y a
un contraste absolument fabuleux féroce
entre ce que zellens qui fait son
apparence et les mots qu'il prononce et
ce qui est en face Vladimir Poutine
engoncé dans un style très soviétique
froid et c'est aussi cette dimension
rationnel le quadra Tesla Apple pay
contre le septuagénaire kg dans les
premières heures ou dans les premiers
jours les discours de Vladimir Poutine
étaient essaient de se faire
effectivement c'était c'était froid et
puis la première image il semblait
totalement écrabouillé derrière un
bureau qui était trois fois plus grand
que lui bon il l'a un peu corrigé aussi
depuis évidemment Alexandre goujon il
parle tous les jours à son peuple ça
continue ça c'est une vidéo quasiment
tous les soirs un peu tard vers vers 23h
voilà selfie vidéo dans différents
endroits souvent à l'administration
présidentielle et oui il communique il a
besoin de maintenir le lien aussi sur
son action en Ukraine
bien sûr c'est un c'est un communicant
mais il y a d'autres communiquant en
Ukraine et les Ukrainiens eux-mêmes sont
des communiquants il y a beaucoup de
choses qui qui circulent sur les sur les
réseaux sociaux donc les Ukrainiens eux
ont besoin d'avoir de l'action qu'est-ce
qu'il fait pas au concret ah oui il se
déplace c'est pour obtenir des armes et
là-dessus on le suit on est d'accord
voilà lorsqu'il y a un scandale de
corruption faut quand même un moment
donné qui se légitime donc en fait la
vie politique continue oui il fait vivre
la démocratie
ukrainienne malgré le
c'est un vrai un vrai souci parce que
aujourd'hui il y a un marathon
télévisuel par exemple qui uniformise
les informations alors que l'Ukraine
était un pays où il y avait des talk
shows avec des députés tous les soirs
qui duraient des heures et qui sont
regardés il y a une vraie animation
politique le journaliste d'investigation
continue c'est extrêmement important les
journalistes qui on va dire ce sont
adaptés à la guerre dans les premiers
mois on continuait leur travail et
certains ils le disent dans dans
plusieurs interviews ont vu des schémas
de corruption et ce sont dit on ne peut
pas laisser passer ça c'est-à-dire que
le les réformes qui ont été engagées
notamment
depuis la révolution de depuis 2014 il
faut absolument qu'on continue il y a de
l'argent qui va venir de l'Union
européenne il y a de l'argent pour la
reconstruction il y a plus d'argent pour
l'armée il faut qu'on s'assure que tout
cela soit bien utilisé il y a des
garde-fous il y a du contre-pouvoir il y
a aussi toute cette question de la
corruption dans la justice et d'ailleurs
on en a un petit peu moins parlé mais
aujourd'hui en fait et bien lors de la
visite de byden les associations de
lutte contre la corruption on dit voilà
ça va être l'occasion de reparler aussi
de sujets sensibles parce qu'on attend
le directeur du bureau national pour la
lutte contre la corruption on attend sa
nomination et la venue de Biden peut
nous aider donc en fait sur l'aspect
j'allais dire des réformes politiques en
tous les cas
zellenski bien sûr il est pris j'allais
dire entre deux types de pression à la
fois la société toute la société civile
qui s'est constituée depuis 2014 et qui
regarde toujours avec un air suspicieux
ces élites politiques on ne sait jamais
ce qu'ils peuvent faire quand bien même
on les suit sur une partie du chemin et
c'est ce qu'ils font aujourd'hui et puis
bien évidemment les bailleurs de fonds
étrangers qui font aussi pression sur le
sur le pouvoir politique mais c'est vrai
que c'est une démocratie en guerre c'est
une démocratie électorale les prochaines
élections étaient prévues législatives
en octobre 2023 la loi martiale
aujourd'hui elle peut être modifiée mais
interdit tout type de scrutin de
d'élection ou de ou de référendum rien
de chemin je vous pose pas une colle
parce que vous disiez on aimerait bien
savoir si un speed doctor ou qui écrit
c'est ses discours je sais pas si
quelqu'un autour de la table à la
réponse mais qu'est-ce qui vous fera de
vous dans le voilà la victoire du verbe
dont on parlait galaïa il y a une petite
une demi douzaine de personnes qui
entourent élanski et qui l'aident ce qui
est intéressant c'est que beaucoup
viennent sont des dialogués sous des
scénaristes beaucoup viennent de sa
maison de production notamment le
principal d'entre eux je crois que c'est
pas une yurioscout et tel qu'il me l'a
raconté en fait il réunit son équipe une
semaine avant un événement comme celui
qu'on a vu par exemple quand il va à
Londres et il leur donne quelques
éléments de de voilà le thème quelques
éléments mais alors peut-être qu'il m'a
dit je ne dis pas ça pour flatter le
président mais c'est quand même lui qui
a toujours les bonnes idées les
meilleures c'est possible parce qu'il en
a beaucoup et voilà il travaille donc en
fait je faisais le parallèle en France
sont plutôt des normalisiens parfois des
énerves plutôt des normalisiens qui
travaillent et là c'est d'abord une
autre génération enfin pas forcément une
autre génération mais c'est un autre
profil qu'on a un peu méprisé en se
disant mais c'est très difficile de
faire une scénario un scénario sitcom il
faut être très intelligent très vif et
voilà c'est ils viennent de au fond d'un
circuit qu'on ne connaît absolument pas
en France je voudrais qu'on parle de la
popularité de de zellenski euh j'ai été
frappé par ce je me souvenais plus de du
score qu'il réalise à la présidentielle
quand il l'emporte 20 mai 2019 il
remporte l'élection présidentielle avec
73,2 % des voix alors évidemment
aujourd'hui il est il est moins
populaire malgré la guerre c'est ça qui
est étonnant aujourd'hui j'ai 10 mois
oui et plus il est au-dessus oui oui
aujourd'hui dans les enquêtes d'opinion
qui qui sont menées et il y en a et à
l'échelle nationale depuis l'extrême
ouest de la Galicie jusque jusque dans
le Dombas
on est au delà de 90
95% donc il y a oui il y a une espèce
d'union sacrée même si comme le disait
très bien Alexandre à goujon moi j'ai
parlé avec des politiciens d'opposition
qu'ils attendaient nous on n'a pas voté
pour lui on le soutient pas
politiquement et d'ailleurs on a tout
intérêt à faire vivre cette démocratie
parce que c'est précisément cela se
défend face à un modèle qui est à
l'opposé de ce que nous ce à quoi nous
aspirons mais aujourd'hui oui non il y a
une union nationale autour de alors je
sais pourquoi j'ai inversé les chiffres
parce que en fait ce qui est intéressant
il s'en va goujon c'est que
sa première moitié de mandat il est
quand même critiqué on a retrouvé un
article un portrait de chez nos
confrères du journal du dimanche février
2020 l'article était titré
ambitieux calculateur et brutal c'est
toujours intéressant de voir comment les
voilà les les adjectifs changent et et
pour cause mais sa popularité elle a
baissé il y a les histoires de
corruption finalement sa première moitié
de mandat et quoi elle est le bilan il
est plutôt il est plutôt négatif
qu'est-ce que vous diriez dans l'opinion
dans l'opinion juste avant l'invasion
Zellen ski il est à peu près à 25 30%
d'opinion favorables mais c'est le plus
populaire des hommes politiques d'accord
donc ça reste quand même une petite
victoire
ça nous permet de voir c'est que il y a
une défiance à l'égard des Hélips
poétiques et puis il y a une forme
d'usure c'est à dire bon bah c'est les
skis arrive au pouvoir et puis deux ans
et demi et bien voilà on est on est
mécontents ce qui n'est pas anormal en
Ukraine c'est c'est d'ailleurs voilà
c'est un parcours de ce point de vue là
c'est un parcours assez classique et
bien évidemment juste après l'invasion
on a cette cote de popularité alors faut
savoir quand même que juste devant
Hélène ski si on fait un sondage sur
l'ensemble des institutions l'armée est
devant aujourd'hui c'est à dire c'est
l'institution aujourd'hui qui est la
plus la plus populaire galère un film
l'histoire des contes offshore c'est
quoi cette histoire
réponse à votre question et c'est l'une
des réponses à votre question Zelenski
c'est les deux piliers si vous voulez de
sa campagne ces deux principales
promesses c'est une la paix ramener la
paix et moi je vais ramener la paix dans
le pays force elle constater que l'échec
est total depuis le 23 février 2022 ou
le 24 et la deuxième promesse c'est la
lutte contre la corruption qui passe
notamment par la désolidarisation et 4
mois avant l’invasion il y a un
collectif de journalistes
d'investigation extraordinaire et
d'ailleurs principalement des
journalistes femmes qui font un travail
d'investigation il faut comprendre que
l'Ukraine quand vous faites cela vous
risquez votre vie c'est-à-dire qu'il y
en a qui le paye de leur vie ce travail
et qui révèle effectivement la présence
du nom volet diverski dans ce qu'on
appelle les Pandoras papers c'est fuite
de millions de documents en provenance
de comptes offshore et qui sont liés à
des comptes d'un oligarque justement
Igor que le mosqui et là je prends juste
une transaction 40 millions de dollars 4
mois avant l'invasion et les Américains
mettent une énorme pression sur
l'administration zellenski en disant dis
donc la lutte contre la corruption la
lutte contre l'oligarisation la loi
contre la des oligarchisations elle en
est où et donc ça patine zenki qui est
quand même une armada d'avocats de
convaincus communicants etc quand ces
journalistes vont vers lui avant
publication ils disent comment est-ce
que vous expliquez cela
il n'y a pas d'explication la seule qui
est fournie c'est de dire oui mais vous
saviez quand on a fait tout cet argent
on n'était pas en politique il fallait
qu'on protège notre argent à la seule
manière de le faire c'était de le sortir
du crâne et là la journaliste lui dit
mais vous êtes au pouvoir aujourd'hui
donc ils disent ah oui ça prend
longtemps de défaire des compteurs etc
donc oui Zelenski il a mis les pains les
mains dans le pot de miel et ce qu'il
explique et il le fait dans le débat
d'entre-deux tours qui l'oppose au
sortant Petro pour auchenko c'est à dire
Petro poroscenco les choses commencent à
sortir sur Zelenski parce que vous savez
les gens qui cherchent sur finit par
trouver c'est pas très difficile en
Ukraine et pour tropéroprojenko les deux
sont sur scène dans le stade olympique
dans le centre de qui et bien mais vous
avez des transactions bizarres vous êtes
liés à des à des oligarques vous
monsieur Hélène ski et là comédien comme
il est est très malin comme il est et ça
c'est des choses qu'il apprend dans le
cadre des KVN c'est à dire la sagacité
et la répartie il dit métropole je vous
confirme qu'en Ukraine c'est impossible
de faire sans les oligarques d'ailleurs
vous monsieur petropo Ginko vous êtes un
oligarque on est obligé de passer par
les gens comme vous donc il ne nie pas
mais il renvoie pétropporigenco à ce
qu'il est et en réalité dans ce moment
on se rend compte que Petro porochenko
effectivement porteur d'un bon message
mais c'est le mauvais message pour le
porter ça c'est qu'il a compris allez on
va parler un peu de la suite de l'avenir
d'un volody merzianski nous reste
malheureusement ça passe trop vite
seulement quelques minutes moins de 5
minutes mais je vous propose une
séquence pour lancer ce chapitre où
finalement on voit un volet dix
meilleurs zalensky face à un très grand
comédien américain c'est Sean Penn qui
est en Ukraine pour pour tourner un film
mais qui je ne peine lui remet l'une de
je ne fais il y a eu deux Oscars en sa
carrière il lui remet l'un de ses Oscars
évidemment c'est très symbolique écoutez
ce dialogue
quand tu gagneras tu me le rapporteras à
malibuer c'était l'un de mes rêves voilà
documentaire sur l'Ukraine intitulé
super power que je ne paye est en train
de tourner alors évidemment rien de
chemin c'est très difficile de
d'imaginer la suite mais moi vous disiez
c'est
Charlot qui devient Churchill il faut se
souvenir que Churchill a été battu aux
élections après la Seconde Guerre
mondiale comment vous imaginez la suite
pour
qui est absolument à la fois fascinant
et tragique dans cette histoire c'est
que on n'imagine pas c'est c'est le
monde est suspendu au fond
aux paroles à l'avenir d'un homme
qu'elle ne connaissait pas on peut dire
quand il était venu en 2019 il y avait
pas beaucoup de gens hormis les
personnes comme vous qui s'occupe qui
s'intéressent à l'Ukraine qui qui s'en
occupait et qui était préoccupé par
l'avenir de l'Ukraine et là tout d'un
coup voilà c'est c'est facile à dire
mais c'est la figure de du héros de la
résistance face à Poutine Alexandre
goujon les critiques elles vont
ressortir forcément on essaie je suis
d'accord avec Ariane c'est très
difficile de se projeter dans dans un
après guerre mais la démocratie qui est
toujours vivante vous nous l'avez
expliqué elle va reprendre ses droits et
donc les critiques ressortiront
peut-être plus fort comment vous voulez
imaginer
la question c'est la question
imiter je reprends traction du chef
d'État en guerre c'est-à-dire combien de
temps elle va durer voilà comment il y a
selon la loi martiale il y a un
renouvellement de mandat puisqu'il y a
pas d'élection comment ça va se passer
comment ça va être légitimé en interne
mais là où vous avez raison c'est que en
fait les Ukrainiens se projettent et
aujourd'hui il y a déjà des discussions
sur comment organiser les élections une
fois qu'on aura gagné comment on va
reconstruire Mario Paul une fois que
Mario Paul sera récupéré c'est à dire il
y a une projection dans l'avenir mais
plutôt dans l'après-guerre si je puis
dire dans dans cette victoire qui est
voulue je le rappelle aussi on a parlé
des sondages aujourd'hui encore les
derniers sondages montrent que 80% des
Ukrainiens plus de 90% des Ukrainiens
croient en la victoire
c'est l'optimisme Chevillot corps quoi
c'est on pourrait dire ça comme ça oui
et les Ukrainiens disent quand vous leur
posez la question nous n'avons pas le
choix
c'est notre aujourd'hui il faut avoir
conscience du fait que c'est comme
Zelenski d'ailleurs quand il fait cette
première vidéo devant l'administration
présidentielle avec avec trois trois
conseillers c'est à dire que nous
n'avons pas le choix nous devons rester
là et nous devons résister parce que
c'est pour les Ukrainiens c'est aussi
leurs enfants on a compris dans les
écoles pas vous mais je me souviens de
nos premiers plateaux on imaginait que
Kev elle est tombée en cas de 5 jours
enfin bon ne pensait pas forcément que
Kieff allait tomber en quatre cinq jours
on a bien compris on l'a bien compris un
dernier mot que je reprends le le
parallèle avec Churchill parce que les
les Britanniques voulaient passer à
autre chose
est-ce que c'est
ça peut arriver quand j'ai vu elenski si
vous voulez dans cet habit kaki qu'il
revêt désormais tous les jours je me
suis demandé si c'était le prochain
fidèle Castro quoi qui va de manière
éternelle jusqu'à son trépas rester au
pouvoir
auréolé d'une gloire passée et avec une
tendance sur la fin autoritaire il a
reçu un Oscar des mains de Sean Penn
vous savez ce que ça veut dire ça veut
dire que en réalité il est en train de
jouer le rôle de sa vie et c'est son
pire ennemi Vladimir Poutine qui le lui
a confié merci beaucoup merci à tous
c'était passionnant ce débat consacré à
volody Mercedes qui donc je vous le
redis chaque chaque jour de cette
semaine on consacrera la seconde partie
de ce sens public à la guerre en
Ukraine demain on va décortiquer les les
conséquences économiques conséquences
économiques évidemment mondialisé d'une
guerre locale vérocité vos livres
évidemment Alexandra goujon l'Ukraine de
l'indépendance à la guerre aux éditions
Le Cavalier Bleu et puis il y a
certaines qui l'Ukraine dans le sang aux
éditions du Rocher rien de cheval on
attend avec impatience le le prochain
vide des Hélène ski dans dans le monde
merci Frédéric à demain c'est Thomas
demain évidemment je vous dis aussi à
demain pour un nouveau numéro de sens
public et puis votre prochain
rendez-vous politique sur notre antenne
dans la matinale rien de Montigny reçoit
Renaud Muselier président de la région
sud ce sera à 8 heures du matin
[Musique]